foreign
let's go to Albany New York and talk to
Ava what's up Ava
hi
what's up
um living the dream
anyone who says they're living the dream
is like for sure not living the dream I
I hope you are living the dream I hope
it's I hope your life is dream worthy
what's up
um can't complain uh well my question is
you could but then you'd be Kelly so
there you go
all right go ahead um my question is uh
what are some considerations when you
are putting together a will as far as
who will be the guardian of our children
um huh tell me more
so um my husband and I have uh two small
kids they're four and five and um we we
don't have a will yet I know we needed I
won two years ago or years ago but um
today today today today today get one
okay yes I yeah
um but how do we pick a guardian
um so I always thought my sister would
be the guardian of our kids we're pretty
close
um but she
you know now has children of her own now
she has a newborn and a two-year-old and
I just I feel like if anything were to
happen to us you know I'm gonna add my
kids who are all close in age two and
you know is that going to be more of a
burden or have you asked her I don't
know
I haven't asked her now ask her you're
spending a lot of time in your head this
is where a lot of people get stuck
because the the the thought of their
kids waking up
I'm gonna get real graphic right now is
that okay
yeah yeah I'll use my kids because it'll
be easier to metabolize the thought of
my son
opening his eyes
and getting hit by that dump truck
of pain
knowing mom and dad are gone
I cannot wrap my head around that
I don't have a picture in my head of my
kid of my daughter
getting up and stumbling out of her room
into the living room and work on
or I know I I have a picture of what her
body posture would be if she walked out
of a strange room down a strange hallway
into a strange kitchen and some other
adults were in there even adults she
knows and Mom and Dad are gone I know
that picture
and I hate it and I don't want it in my
mind
right
yeah it's easier to not think about but
I know it's something that we have to
you know yes ask them have a plan and
because if you don't you're just
suggesting not suggesting you are saying
to the state of New York we would prefer
that you all make this decision not us
and
I don't live in New York but from afar I
wouldn't put a ton of trust in that
government at this moment
nope
all right
um and that's not even just goes for New
York it goes for any state government
so we're faced with I don't want to
imagine this
and so when we don't want to imagine
something we get in everybody else's
head around us and we create stories in
their heads
and ends up shutting us down we end up
not moving forward we won't do anything
so step number one is ask your sister if
that's the person that's the person
here's a couple things I'm going to look
for number one
um
I want values to be in the in the in the
neighborhood right
they might go to this church over this
church but if you want your kids raised
with a certain
um Faith tradition that needs to be a
part of it right also knowing that their
faith tradition may change when they're
15 or 16 or whatever or the people
raising your kids might change just like
yours might change that happens that's
life you can't predict every variable
out but I also want people that I've
seen have their own kids
and they're doing pretty good job at it
like I like how they raise their kids I
like how they handle conflict I like how
they don't freak out or they don't yell
or whatever the thing is
the third thing
um
and
this one's this one's tougher um and I
might be in the minority on this one and
so if people want to make comments make
comments about me not about you Ava
um
but I want people in my local community
that my Ki it will minimize the
um it will minimize the transfer to my
kids what does that mean
um my family is all in Texas my closest
friends in the world are all in Texas
uh if I lived in Texas and my friends
and I who they're over at my house all
the time and my family who's around it
would be a no-brainer that my kids would
go with one of them
but now I've been in Nashville Tennessee
for five years
that world is foreign to my kids they
don't know those people like I do they
don't have those long-term relationships
it would be terrifying and
tragically uprooting to pick them up
from everything they know in terms of
sidewalks and schools and grass and
weather and drop them in the middle of
y'all just go do life there
and so we worked really hard to find
people in our local community that we
felt great about
and we asked them and they said sure and
we
probably every 18 months or so we
probably need to be a little bit better
about it but we re-up are we still good
does this still make sense for us me and
my wife and does this still make sense
for them
and if it is we let them know here's
where our will is here's what um our
financial situation will be and y'all's
financial situation will be and quite
honestly I don't have a ton of crazy
restrictions on it
because if they take my kid and and my
two kids they may have to get another
house they get my two kids they may have
to alter how they live and if I don't
trust them enough with my with my money
then why in the world would I trust me
with my kids
uh I guess that was like another part of
my question is
um so yeah originally I had thought that
like also we all we have different
personal views on on money specifically
um uh so we like me and my husband we
have life insurance in place and
um yeah my husband brought up like wow
if we both die they're gonna get like
you know all this money and life
insurance like are they going to be
responsible with it you can put it in a
trust that they'll like love my children
but you can put that money into trust
that would be dispersed to your kids at
varying ages 16 18 25 30 whatever
um and also there's a trust that would
disburse money to
your whoever takes your kids that's just
you sitting down with a with a tax Pro
but Kelly's talking to me hey sorry
suicide we've done this recently okay
um you can also we have someone that
takes our children you know should
something happen and we did the same
thing you did John
um it's not our families because our
families aren't local and they don't you
know so it's it's a local friend but
also somebody else has Financial
oversight uh somebody who I trust
implicitly who has the financial
oversight so any any expenditures in
anything from the trust would go through
someone else so that the person living
with them is not necessarily
you know for the money yeah so I I I I
know this I know that I trust the people
who I'm going to leave my kids to
implicitly I also know
because of where I work and the work
that I do if you have I don't know what
your life insurance policy is let's say
it's two million dollars
I also know somebody holding a check for
two million dollars changes them
instantly right
so maybe having some sort of oversight
um from a third party
who would would oversee like well I
can't give you a million dollars you
don't need a million dollar house now
suddenly um or we need to make sure this
goes to college education and this goes
to the wedding and this goes to a car so
however you all divide it up is great
however y'all however y'all break it up
and maneuver that's all well and good
but it's just you and your husband being
on the same page and letting them know
like Hey sister I'd love for you to keep
my kids we love
um we'd love for you to be the guardian
of our kids are you still in I know that
you've got two kids
um great hey grandparents we would love
for to put you down as the Guardians
um and hey best friends hey whoever
and give them permission to say yay or
nay and if they say nay okay great
they've got their reasons it's not
personal great I'm so grateful that they
gave you boundaries they didn't just say
yes out of obligation and they're gonna
have to raise a couple of kids they
don't like so good for them they said no
awesome we're moving on or they said yes
fantastic then we're gonna have a
conversation about here's where the will
is here is how we would disperse any
life insurance money and what that would
look like and like Kelly we have a third
party like uh like me and my family
here's a big chunk to y'all we also have
this money to trust however that works
for you and the trust has a custodian
too who makes sure that that happens how
are we all doing great just let them let
everybody be on the same page as though
you and your husband ran for a quick
date tonight to get coffee and y'all are
hit by a car
um
and I wish that it wasn't that cut and
dry I've just
had to tell too many kids that their
parents have died or I've had to tell
too many parents that their kids have
died over the course of my career and it
just happens it just happens
any tips on um it sounds like a very
uncomfortable Converse
bring up like hey out of the blue what
are you doing tonight and uh will you be
the guardian of our children it's just
that bluntly or any tips on how to like
bring it up or I would say hey I need to
have a a hard personal conversation with
you nothing bad's going on
um but this is Sister to Sister
okay or friend of friend
I think if if I'm not mistaken I think
I texted
our friends here
and I remember thinking it was the
funniest thing because that's like one
of the most important decisions of my
entire life and I texted it to him
but we were going to get together and we
couldn't or whatever and they're like
what do you want to talk about and I
think I had made it kind of weird which
my wife says I do all the time on the
front end I think they were asking if we
were gonna like do if I they were
interested like a wife swap or something
I made it such a huge deal like all
right this is gonna be a huge deal I
know it's gonna be kind of weird and
y'all don't freak out and so I think I
overdid it on the front end and but then
we couldn't get together for some
something happened and I ended up
texting him and I remember sitting there
going you should be ashamed of yourself
you just texted that but here's the
thing it gave them and it gave them
permission to not make a weird face in
front of me it gave them permission to
be like no and then come around to like
no this is actually pretty awesome it
gave them permission to do that so um
maybe if you if you need to say hey I'm
going to send you a letter the letter is
going to be weird
just let me know
and I'll call you in a week after you
get this letter if that's more
comfortable for you cool there's
something about letting people digest it
I don't need an answer right now
um maybe an answer in 10 days in two
weeks but we need to get this ironed out
we haven't done this yet and it's really
important
um and go from there and be prepared
they may not ask you to keep their kids
on the back end that's fine they've got
their reasons it's all good
how does that sound
that sounds good I mean it's just yeah
none of this is fun if you enjoy this
process you should probably go see
somebody
right if you enjoy making plans for how
your kids are going to navigate the
world when you're dead if that's fun for
you
you listen to a lot of murder podcasts
okay here's the here's the last thing
I'll throw out there
the Temptation is to try to mitigate
every variable
here's the hard hard truth
if two parents if were to die if me and
my wife were to die suddenly
and left my seven-year-old little girl
and my 13 year old little boy in the
world to make their way
even with the most extraordinary
Guardian
they've been thrown into the dark sea
for a while
and so to think on this side of that
level of trauma that I can mitigate
every variable and every if then is
nonsense it's a waste of energy it's me
exerting false fake control over a
situation that I won't have any control
over because I'll be dead
and so there is an element of trust to
this process there's an element of I'm
going to insure myself to the hilt so
that there is no Financial concerns when
they're in the middle of the ocean
trying to tread water I'm going to make
sure they've got men and women around
them that love them and see the world in
their best interest
so when they're in their deep dark sea
and I'm going to make sure that I've got
um
that they know on a daily basis
starting right now
just how loved and strong and capable
they are
and really at the end of the day I'm
going to keep my hands open after that
I struggle with that I may uh type a
list maker checklist kind of person and
there is no list to be made if Mom and
Dad both go that's not true there is a
list it's a very it's a much shorter one
than you think than you think it is
right
um it's a much shorter than one than you
think it is
but good for you like good for you for
recognizing it you've got to got to got
to get a will
um and I'll say this when I moved to
Nashville I had a really extensive
um will made up in Texas I just happened
to be colleagues with one of the
greatest wills and trust attorneys on
the planet and um so he gave I mean it
was it was amazing and it didn't
transfer to a new state so I got with
Mama Bear Wills it's online company do
we have a discount with him guys
yes we do if you go on
ramseysolutions.com use code Dave's
deals okay at checkout you get 20 off
okay that's what I did that's what I did
for my family to bridge the gap between
sitting down and getting a full
financial plan and
I'm not having anything not having
nothing right so uh make sure make sure
make sure even if you go to mama bear
tonight and just say okay we got to get
something down in case I die on the way
to work tomorrow which across this
country will happen I don't want to be
Debbie Downer but it will happen
I hope that none of the listeners on
this show God I hope none of those
listeners on the show but
you have to just go to Mom bear wills
and put that out there great and if you
want to get a more extensive trust and a
bigger plan all that kind of stuff great
do that set up those appointments get
that stuff knocked out but you got to
get that stuff done done done protect
your kids protect your assets protect
your family protect your community
for the day not if but when you're gone
thank you so so much for this important
call Ava